[Music]
what's a free coding resource you could
never do without
free coding resource that I could never
do without is definitely github both git
and github for keeping track of of code
and managing large software projects
probably Jupiter notebooks it's an
interactive sort of console to type code
and visualize whatever your whatever
data you're working with and it makes it
really easy to do to work on projects
interactively and quickly it could
probably never do is out Stack Exchange
where it's just a lot of programmers
coming together and giving each other's
answers to their problems Stack Overflow
is incredible I probably use it at least
ten times that they took Google to
figure out what my what what's the quick
in my program Stack Overflow is the most
incredible website where if you just
need to do something and you've no idea
how to get started you type it into
Google and probably the first result is
a Stack Overflow result saying this is
how you solve this problem that I think
has really revolutionized both the
democratization of coding because people
can go and figure out how to solve their
problem with their stuff and also has
really sort of created this great
community online where people can ask
and answer questions definitely Stack
Overflow
I feel like if Stack Overflow ever went
down or if they decided to charge for it
the entire programming community would
just go up in flames
[Music]
you